bien en el vídeo pasado en la recta
final nosotros nos dimos cuenta de las
restricciones en términos de ve para la
línea que están gente para el círculo y
la hipérbola ahora déjame hacer una
aclaración aquí pues en el vídeo pasado
tomé una raíz principal cuando hice la
raíz cuadrada y esto es porque quiero
que la intersecte positivamente recuerda
cuando vemos este dibujo que realicé en
el primer vídeo de esta serie la
intersectan necesitando ser positiva
pues debemos tener una pendiente
positiva y que sea tangente al círculo y
a la hipérbola de esta forma y entonces
aquí abajo definitivamente vamos a
querer tener la raíz principal lo que
esto nos dice es que esta vez la
restricción en cuanto la hipérbola y
está de por acá nos va a decir que es la
restricción en cuanto al círculo
entonces vamos a igualar una con otra
tenemos aquí la raíz cuadrada de 9 m
cuadrada vamos a poner por aquí la raíz
de 9 m cuadrada menos 4 que esto va a
ser igual al menos 4 m va a ser igual de
otro color a menos 4 m más 4 veces
y de m cuadrada 1 así que la primera
cosa que podemos realizar aquí es quitar
las raíces de ambos lados por lo que de
este lado tendríamos 9 m cuadrada menos
4 en el otro lado habría que elevar al
cuadrado y entonces este al cuadrado el
primer término va a ser 16 m cuadrada se
va al signo negativo y luego dos veces
el producto de estos dos términos va a
ser dos veces el producto de estos dos
términos menos 16 m cuadrada por 2 lo
que esto nos va a quedar menos 32 m por
la raíz dm cuadrada +1 y finalmente ese
término al cuadrado vendría siendo 16
por m cuadrada más 1 ahora
simplifiquemos esto un poco y obtener
tal vez un radical de algunos de los
lados de la ecuación para lograr obtener
m pero veamos cómo podemos simplificarlo
porque a veces se puede simplificar
incluso aún más hay que ser cuidadosos y
para empezar para empezar bien vamos a
desarrollar este término sería 16 m
cuadrada
16 y de nuestro lado izquierda pues ya
teníamos de color magenta en 9 m
cuadrada menos 4 que esto va a ser igual
tenemos dos veces 16 m cuadrada entonces
esto va a ser 32 m cuadrada 32 m
cuadrada más 16 menos 32 por m veces m
cuadrada la raíz de m cuadrada más 1
ahora también podemos sustraer o restar
9 m cuadrada por ambos lados lo que
tendríamos menos 9 m cuadrada de ambos
lados y luego también podríamos sumar 4
por ambos lados todo esto lo estoy
haciendo para simplificar mi ecuación y
exploramos adoptando alterarla
pero pero creo que no creo que mejor le
voy a restar por ambos lados 32 m
cuadrada menos 32 m cuadrado de este
lado menos 32 en el cuadrado también de
este lado y también de ambos lados vamos
a restarle 16 vamos a restar 16 de
mirada izquierdo tendríamos 9 m cuadrada
menos 32 m cuadrada aunque en realidad
lo que estás
anteriormente también estaba bien pero
aquí para simplificar más rápido mi
ecuación entonces menos 32 más 9 me
cuadrada nos va a quedar menos nos
quedan menos 23 m cuadrada y luego
tenemos menos 16 menos 4 esto nos quedan
menos 20 esto de por aquí nos va a
quedar menos 32 m por la raíz de
cuadrada más 1 se están cancelando
prácticamente varios términos y ahora
ahora podemos elevar a ambas partes
también de la ecuación para que
eliminemos otra vez la raíz y esto no
está siendo lo más limpio del mundo
espero no cometan ningún error cuando
usted les toque resolver este tipo de
cosas y bueno multiplican las partes
también de la ecuación por un -1 para
por estética matemática prácticamente
ahora de mi lado izquierdo de la
ecuación vamos a tener 23 al cuadrado
23m cuadrada mejor y todo esto a su vez
al cuadrado más 2 veces el producto de
estos dos términos que sería dos veces
por 20 por 23 para no hacer tanta cuenta
todavía por m cuadrada más 20 al
cuadrado que viene siendo 400 y todo
esto
a 332 m y todo esto al cuadrado por m
cuadrada más 1 y veamos qué podemos
hacer por aquí esto se va a tornar en
ser un problema un poco tedioso como lo
estaba pensando pero bueno vamos a tener
aquí 23 m cuadrada al todo esto al
cuadrado más y esto es esto es 40 por 23
m cuadrada lo que nos va a dar nos va a
dar 23 x 20 x 2 nos va a dar 920 x m
cuadrada pero déjame déjame expander
todo mejor de una vez voy a tratar de
reducir mejor números para perros
haciendo bien entonces 23 por 23 aquí
esto es por 39 luego 3 por 26 aquí
ponemos un 0 2 por 3 62 por 24 y al
hacer esta suma nos va a dar 96 al 612
llevamos una 415 en 3 529 por lo que
aquí entonces tenemos 529 por m al
cuadrado al cuadrado en mi cuarta
y como habíamos dicho 23 por 20 por 2
tendrá 140 por 23 y al hacer esta
operación nos viene resultando 920 por m
al cuadrado más 400 y esto a su vez va a
ser igual a su vez va a ser igual
tenemos aquí otra vez un 32 al cuadrado
hagamos la operación también estrado sea
32 por 32 esto vendría siendo como lo
dije anteriormente de verdad esto
resulta un tanto pues tedioso por las
cuentas y si esto fuera un examen te
tendrás que saber prácticamente las
tablas de multiplicar hasta el 50 pero
creo que esto en sí no tiene como un
gran propósito pero como te digo si esto
realmente es un examen ellos se van a
fijar en que obtengas las cuentas
perfectas entonces no hay excusa y yo
creo que yo creo que si nos pusiéramos a
pensar del porcentaje que en la india
realmente realiza esto estas grandes
cuentas pues no están por debajo del 80%
y son más o menos capaces de resolver
las secciones matemáticas y como les
comentaba a cerca de un 80 por ciento y
es realmente grandioso pero tendríamos
que hacer como
un umbral para obtener un porcentaje
cercano a esto yo creo que yo podría en
estos momentos llegarle a un 40 a un 50
por ciento si es por por mucho decir
porque así no soy tan buena memorizando
no me gusta memorizar las cuentas
entonces si me puse a aprenderme todo
esto realmente sería tedioso yo prefiero
como analizarlo y aquí como como vimos
tuvimos el tiempo suficiente para
analizar cómo la llevó el eje de la
siesta o la lleva a interceptar a la
hiper voy a la de la circunferencia y
realmente no me refiero con esto que sea
malo memorizar tú lo haces en tu vida
diaria pero simplemente creo que estamos
hablando de cosas matemáticas y sería
más importante que realmente las
entendidas a que memorizar as y
siguiendo con nuestra cuenta este 32 por
32 nos arroja un 1024 y era 32 por m al
cuadrado entonces es 1024 x m al
cuadrado y a su vez por m cuadrada más 1
y desarrollando esto nos quedan 1024 x m
a la cuarta más
1024 por m cuadrada y ahora que estamos
en la recta final vamos a restar de
ambos lados otra vez para no alterar la
ecuación 529 por m 4a
de tal forma realmente esto se está
haciendo demasiado tedioso yo lo sé y
francamente en este punto de problemas
si tú eres realmente rápido para
resolver las cuentas creo que vas a
tener un resultado más satisfactorio que
el que yo estoy teniendo pero en fin
y no con esto quiere decir que vayamos
más simplemente que a mí me cuesta un
poco de trabajo visualizar qué es lo que
hay que cancelar o las cuentas que hay
que realizar pero bueno vamos a observar
y también nos convendría entonces restar
de ambos lados de la ecuación una vez
más el 920 por m cuadrado menos 920 por
m cuadrada y realizamos esta esta resta
también si te das cuenta nos conviene
cancelar a este lado el 400 entonces
serían menos 400 de ambos lados y así ya
de este lado de la ecuación vamos a
obtener 0 y esto va a ser igual a igual
o sea 1024 en la cuarta menos 529 por m
la cuarta y esto nos va a dar un
resultado de al realizar la resta de 495
por m a la cuarta espero haberlo hecho
bien 10 mil 24 m la cuarta menos 529
m la cuarta si te gusta realizar tu
operación por otro lado está perfecto
pero si es 495 y luego tenemos 10 mil 24
menos 97 por m cuadrada menos 920 por m
cuadrada y esto vendría siendo más 104 m
cuadrada y todo esto a menos 400 y ahora
así como observamos simplemente tenemos
una ecuación cuadrática y la vamos a
resolver como nosotros normalmente
sabemos que no te espante está m a la
cuarta es lo mismo que si escribimos
como m la cuarta pues lo mismo que m al
cuadrado al cuadrado y vamos a
resolverlo y nosotros tenemos m cuadrado
y no nos va a causar mayor problema m
cuadrada va a ser igual sustituyendo la
m cuadrada como la fórmula cuadrática
entonces sustituyendo cada valor para
lo que representa como el coeficiente
sería menos 104 más menos la raíz más
menos la raíz debe cuadrada que es 104
al cuadrado otra vez cuentas infinitas
sin calculadora pero bueno no importa es
menos cuatro veces 495 que es la x menos
porsche que es menos 400 entonces se nos
convierte este en positivo y todo esto a
su vez sobre dos veces a que sea dos
veces 495 y si realizamos la cuenta es
495 por 2 nos va a arrojar un resultado
de 990 ahora vamos a empezar a ver si
podemos evaluar o ver lo que nos arrojan
estos valores para ver qué panorama nos
da respecto a la m cuadrada y
simplemente son cálculos es un poco de
aritmética y esto realmente lo voy a
hacer en el siguiente vídeo para ver lo
que nos va a figurar